l'art ancien du tatouage inspire tout à
la fois respect ou répulsion fantaisie
ou crainte son empreinte inscrits sous
la surface de la peau raconte des
histoires d'espoir de passion de
bravoure et de conquête
le tatouage c'est la marque d'un artiste
sur le canevas de la peau ses origines
remontent à la nuit des temps
[Musique]
j'ai adoré voir le premier tatouage
jamais réalisé de voir cette marque fait
par l'homme primitif quels qu'ils soient
à l'idée que ce soit sa propre marque
c'était un peu comme l'invention de la
roue
[Musique]
faut-il voir les traces retrouvées sur
un chasseur de l'âge de bronze morts il
y environ 5000 ans comme la
représentation du premier tatouage
[Musique]
comment est il possible que ces petites
inclusion eaux noires de charbon et pu
évoluer jusqu'à ses représentations en
couleurs qui sont devenus à travers les
siècles de véritable phénomène
d'identification sociale ou
représentatives des exploits sexuels ou
de lutte détenus
[Musique]
pourquoi dans certaines cultures le
tatouage est il singh doute rage de
dédain ou de persécution religieuse
[Musique]
comment expliquer cette macabre joie des
européens et du 19e siècle à
collectionner les têtes tatouées des
guerriers maoris de nouvelle-zélande
ce qui me fascine dans l'art du tatouage
c'est la diversité des formes qu'il
prend et les différentes interprétations
auxquelles il est sujet
rejoignez nous dans l'exploration de ce
pouvoir mystérieux et de ses
significations cachées de cette
expression artistique très ancienne
[Musique]
en 1991 une expédition d'archéologues
fit une amusante découverte dans les
alpes italiennes
le corps d'un chasseur disparu il ya
environ 5000 ans fut découvert dans un
état de conservation parfait congelé
dans la glace
[Musique]
cette découverte n'est pas en soi
phénomène unique ce qui l'est davantage
et qui fascina les chercheurs c'est le
fait que l'homme portait sur le dos et
au genou de nombreuses lignes dessinées
sur la peau
séduite
etions-nous en présence du premier
tatouage préhistorique
[Musique]
quel était donc cette technique et à
quand remontait cette pratique
[Musique]
rinerson c'est réellement à quand
remonte l'art du tatouage ce que l'on
sait c'est que si on frotte un morceau
de charbon de bois sur une coupure la
marque reste c'est vraisemblablement
l'expérience faite par les hommes
préhistoriques qui est la résultante
probable c'est qu'ils ont créé une série
de coupures comme un motif et que c'est
devenu un tatouage
en fait personne ne sait quand cela a
débuté mais beaucoup pensent qu'il
s'agit là d'un développement de croyance
profonde
le tatouage est probablement l'une des
formes de décoration ou de parures la
plus distinctive fait par l'homme et
cela dans toute l'histoire de la
civilisation
peut-être aussi l'un des premiers
indicateurs de la présence d'une
civilisation
existe-t-il un rapprochement entre les
premières peintures rupestres et lé
premier tatouage
chez les égyptiens on a découvert dans
leurs tombes d art fab bien surprenant
sous forme de talisman comportant des
tatouages et surnommait les fiancés de
la mort
[Musique]
la croyance attribués à ces talismans
c'est qu'ils accompagnaient les hommes
sur le territoire de la mort et qu'il
l'ait revitalise est sur le plan sexuel
[Musique]
en 1891 des archéologues qui travaillait
dans la chambre funéraire du roi amène
tout au tap faire une découverte
remarquable
[Musique]
il exhume r les restes d'une momie
vieille de 2000 ans une prêtresse
égyptienne du nom de hamou net
son abdomen et ses jambes étaient
couverts de tatouages
dans les premiers jours du christianisme
temps périlleux pour les nouveaux
croyants le moindre tatouage était un
dernier
[Musique]
vous ne devez en aucun cas faire la
moindre remarque sur votre chère et
honorer la mort ou tatouer la moindre
remarque sur votre peau
en dépit des injonctions de la bible
beaucoup parmi les premiers chrétiens
étaient à tous et pourquoi cette
désobéissance par rapport aux dogmes
un
moyen de distinguer ceux qui parmi eux
étaient de vrais chrétiens des autres et
comme plutôt la circoncision des juifs
est une manière particulièrement sévère
de distinguer qu'ils étaient juifs ou ne
l'était pas
[Musique]
certains des premiers chrétiens
justifiait cette pratique en se référant
à un détail de la vie de saint paul
il croyait que celui ci portait sur son
corps les traces des souffrances de
jésus sur la croix
[Musique]
désormais comme le laisse en paix
je porte sur mon corps les stigmates de
jésus
lettre au gala siens
est ce pour autant que ces mondes saint
paul sont la marque d'une rupture par
rapport à la bible et de son allégeance
au christ
[Musique]
il semble que les premiers chrétiens
portait de petites croix sous forme de
tatouage à l'intérieur des poignets
dissimulé aux regards des romains qui
n'aimait ni les chrétiens ni les
tatouages
[Musique]
en ce temps là la découverte de ce signe
des synonymes d'une mort certaine
[Musique]
le tatouage avait ce pouvoir qu'aucun
autre symbole ne possédait son côté
irréversible surtout à cette période
vous ne pouviez l'effacer c'était comme
un engagement permanent
pas seulement marque sur la peau mais
plus encore l'appartenance à une
croyance surtout dans le cadre de
christianisme une notion irrévocable
la permanence du tatouage si le point de
non retour et il est considéré comme un
rite de passage d'une étape de vie à la
suivante
et ce n'est pas forcément vrai de
quelque chose d'autre d'une forme de
décoration que vous pouvez retirer ou
effacer
le tatouage c'est une expression avis
dans le courant des années 325 le
tatouage fut encore une fois attaqué
sous le règne de l'empereur constantin
converti au christianisme
de païens lempire allait devenir l'
empire romain catholique et constantin
devenir le zélote de cette nouvelle
religion
son interprétation stricte de la bible
allait renforcer l'aversion pour le
tatouage
constantin avait décrété que le corps
humain à l'image de son créateur devait
rester intacte
le tatouage fut bannie au 4e siècle dans
les sociétés européennes
le tatouage avait quasiment disparu
[Musique]
au
sol une secte de chrétiens égyptiens les
coptes continuèrent à se tatouer
l'intérieur de leur poignée de petites
[Musique]
ce fut le début d'une tradition qu'ils
allaient constituer l'un des phénomènes
les plus sophistiqués le tatouage
religieux
[Musique]
faire de craps pour les coptes le
tatouage religieux était considérée
comme une des formes d'engagement et de
dévotion à l'égard de l'enseignement du
christ
la plus engagée
c'est chez les coptes que l'on trouve la
forme iconographique la plus complexe de
tatouage précisé
pendant la guerre sainte et les
croisades du 10ème et 11ème siècle les
combattants portaient fréquemment la
croix de jérusalem en tatouage
[Musique]
ils étaient effrayés à l'idée de mourir
au combat et pour être enterré dans leur
religion ils pensaient qu'une marque
d'appartenance à la chrétienté les
aiderait
une fois les croisades terminé la
pratique du tatouage disparus dans
l'ouest européen
mais dans d'autres parties du monde cet
art resta florissant et commence à même
à prendre des signification plus
profonde
[Musique]
nous allons maintenant examiner ce qui
se cache derrière le travail artistique
minutieux pratiquée sur le corps dans le
japon ancien
l'instinct de décoration du corps est
universel autant que les tatouages sont
l'expression de celui qui les porte
mais nulle part ailleurs en dehors du
japon cet art est porté à de tels
sommets
[Musique]
de manière étonnante en raison de loi
très restrictive datant du milieu du
xviiie siècle qui réservait au sol plus
riches le droit de porter des kimonos
orné de broderies très sophistiqué l'art
du tatouage s'est développée dans les
autres classes sociales
[Musique]
non
elles se sont senties offensées avait
peu de ressources
mais beaucoup d'ingéniosité
[Musique]
les marchands et d'autres classes
sociales se rebellèrent et se faire
tatouer
c'était des tatouages très élaborée qui
démarrait du coup pour finir aux épaules
qui pouvaient couvrir le dos est allée
jusqu'aux genoux
c'était une forme de consommation cacher
complètement masqué par le port d'une
tenue ordinaire
en 1870 le gouvernement japonais fait un
pas de plus pour bannir les tatouages
[Musique]
c'était le début d'une nouvelle période
dans les relations internationales
[Musique]
gouvernement japonais était un peu
embarrassé à propos de certaines
traditions et les tatouages en faisait
partie ils pensaient qu aux yeux des
européens cela pouvait paraître barbares
et grotesque
le tatouage de vente illégale et les
artistes à cette période fear profil bas
les publicités et on ne pouvait se faire
tatouer que si on connaissait les
arcanes
le tatouage était considéré comme
subversif et s'était implicitement une
manière de flou et l'autorité et cela
rendait le tatouage attractif en
particulier chez les yakuzas les gangs
japonais
[Musique]
habituellement chez les yakuzas le
tatouage prend une dimension féroce
conflictuelles et c'est ce qui en fait
le côté intéressant c'est toujours un
conflit non résolu et un affrontement
entre deux forces égales
les yakuza sont fiers de leur esprit
guerrier et la représentation de leurs
croyances nécessite de souffrir pendant
de longues séances sous les mains des
artistes pour réaliser des tatouages à
la mesure de leur engagement criminelle
cela représente l'engagement d'une vie à
leur groupe et comme c'est illégal le
tatouage devient leur badge de hors la
loi
[Musique]
un autre aspect de la popularité du
tatouage provient d'un ouvrage très
populaire intitulée suikoden dans lequel
une bande de hors la loi défie les
règles d'une civilisation corrompus
les héros de ce livre sont tous
savamment tatoué et le style les
illustrations de l' ouvrage reprennent
les grands archétypes du tatouage
japonais
[Musique]
avec le temps les raisons de se faire
tatouer ont évolué
de l'idée de rebellions contre une loi
répressive on est passé à une forme
d'art et à l'expression de croyances
religieuses
[Musique]
pour tout dire les gens aiment les
tatouages
ils pensent que c'est beau ils veulent
aussi élevé leur sens spirituel il
aimerait construire leur force
intérieure avec patience et persévérance
et la foi en quelque sorte y trouve
aussi sa part
une parure complète du corps évolué
toute la vie et chaque artiste va y
contribuer à sa manière
[Musique]
japon être tatoués est un véritable
engagement pour la vie c'est une
véritable oeuvre qui couvre tout le
corps pas un simple petit détail comme
ici
la personne qui désire se faire tatouer
choisit en général un sujet un
personnage qui le désirent un carnet
emblématique de courage et de loyauté
ces caractères sont porteur d'
importante signification traditionnels
tous les sens c'est magique ainsi une
personne qui se fait tatouer pense que
cela transformera sa vie son âme
[Musique]
plus le tatouage devient populaire et
plus on voit se développer de nouveaux
motifs
des histoires de valeur ou de
persécution disparus font leur
apparition dans les demandes
dans une nation qui a toujours favorisé
une culture très homogène c'est ironique
que ce soit au japon qu'on ait vu se
développer les tendances les plus
abouties tant par les couleurs que dans
les sujets
et c'est ainsi que cachés sous les
vêtements les porteurs de ces
remarquables motifs savent qu'un jour
ils livreront leurs secrets aux mines
[Musique]
en
à l'origine le tatouage japonais devait
rester hors de la vue des autres et cela
en raison du sentiment d' interdit qu'il
véhicule et somme ne faut pas oublier
que le tatouage est un signe de force de
persévérance mais imaginons que
quelqu'un puisse porter son tatouage
cacher et 15 jours parce que le moment
est venu de le dévoiler et de le montrer
aux autres les japonais trouvé ce moment
très beau moment
[Musique]
au début du xviiie siècle les marins
européens tombés par hasard sur un
groupe de gens déroutant
[Musique]
les habitait un grand quart du monde les
îles du sud et du centre du pacifique
[Musique]
là parmi les habitants de ces îles le
tatouage était en vagues depuis
plusieurs générations
[Musique]
et d'une île à l'autre les motifs évolué
et changé en reflétant la culture locale
à tahiti les fesses d'une fille pouvait
être tatoués entièrement en noir à
partir de sa maturité sexuelle
hawaï le tatouage traditionnel de deuil
consiste en trois points sur la langue
[Musique]
à bornéo les populations locales ont un
oeil tatoué dans la paume de la main
comme un guide spirituel qui les guidera
jusqu'à leur prochaine vie
[Musique]
certains sont extrêmement décoratifs
d'autres sont le signe d'un rite
initiatique où d'une célébration
d'autres enfin sont des symboles
guerrier destinée à intimider les
adversaires
[Musique]
chaque groupe d'îles à sa propre légende
sur l'origine du tatouage
ainsi à tahiti c'était le dieu tout est
au beau et hoarau a peint tous les
poissons avec les couleurs leurs motifs
et comme les hommes aiment les motifs
des poissons ils ont commencé à les
copier sur leur propre corps
[Musique]
un européen a décrit les habitants de
ces îles comme ayant la peau cousu de
soi
[Musique]
après les européens avaient une approche
répulsive voir curieuse à l'égard du
tatouage d'un côté il était intrigué et
voyez le tatouage comme signe d'une
culture bar bars et exotiques de l'autre
il y avait de leur part un manque de
compréhension de l'aspect culturel et
donc une certaine répulsion
d'un côté les missionnaires essayer
d'éradiquer cette pratique de l'autre
les marins eux étaient plutôt intrigués
non seulement ils revinrent avec des
tatouages ou des indigènes tatoué mais
de plus ils commencèrent à imposer leurs
propres motifs aux autochtones
[Musique]
en
1769 le célèbre explorateur james cook
débarqua à tahiti et le mot aux
tatouages entra dans la langue anglaise
[Musique]
vient du mot tahitien et du samoa tata
ou tata taux liés aux gestes du tap tap
l'incrustation répétées de marques sur
le corps c'est donc du pacifique que
nous tenons non seulement l'armée le mot
lui-même
en nouvelle zélande cook rencontrera les
maoris qui décorait eux mêmes leurs
visages de tatouages faciaux très
élaboré
[Musique]
le tatouage facial maori le mot cool et
est riche de sens la moindre partie du
visage qui est tatoué l'est en référence
avec la famille s'apparenter son lignage
sa provenance géographique et les buts
de la vie
[Musique]
quand les européens demandèrent aux
maoris de signer des traités ou d'autres
documents ces derniers voulaient
dessiner leurs mots coulent et en guise
de signature
quand le capitaine cook repris le chemin
de l'europe en 1775 il ramenait avec lui
un polynésien du nom de aux mailles qui
avaient le corps couvert de tatouages
oh my pensait-il aiderait peut-être à la
compréhension du tatouage en europe
[Musique]
du capitaine cook
les anglais et les européens à
considérer les gens tatoués comme des
sauvages savez tous
ce que le capitaine cook découvrit avec
oman c'est qu'il était un homme d'une
grande dignité
et des royals d'un grand sang-froid et
parfaitement équilibré
pour une personne tatoué il représentait
une image qui n'avait jusqu'alors jamais
été prise en considération
[Musique]
en partie à cause daumail le tatouage de
vin une pratique rechercher du gentleman
européen et le tatouage pris de
nouvelles formes
[Musique]
quand la royauté européenne utilisa les
tatouages ce fut davantage en relation
avec des images de leur monde
beaucoup plus qu'au travers des images
perçues
plutôt que de se tatouer le visage comme
les maoris
ce furent des dragons qu'il dessinait
sur leurs biceps leurs épaules leur
coude autant de symboles liés à la
royauté
et à leur univers
al'inverse des représentations primitive
mais des dérapages eurent lieu dans les
années 1820 c'est ainsi qu'un marché a
commencé à se développer en europe
autour des têtes tatouées des maoris
à partir de l'instant où les guerriers
maoris apprirent que les collectionneurs
européens aux frais des fusils contre
des têtes tatouées cette pratique
grotesque déclenché un véritable carnage
si la fourniture d'armes étaient
inépuisables tel n'était pas le cas des
têtes d'atouts et
[Musique]
avant peut les maoris furent victimes de
mesures innommable
[Musique]
les esclaves et autres serviteurs
capturé dans les combats et est tatoué
tués et leurs têtes vendus
on a rapporté un incident lors d'un
échange entre un capitaine européen et
un chef maori
alors que ce dernier apportait 12 têtes
en échange de fusil l'européen trouve à
la qualité médiocre
le chef maori demanda alors au capitaine
de choisir parmi ces douze meilleurs
guerriers élevé promis leur tête pour la
semaine suivante à ce rythme là personne
ne pouvait y échapper et la conséquence
fut la disparition de cette pratique de
tatouage c'est
[Musique]
elle
c'est finalement en 1831 que le
gouvernement britannique promulguer une
loi interdisant l'importation de tête
humaine
s sous l'effet de la loi ou le manque de
matières premières toujours est il que
cette pratique sinistre s'arrêta
[Musique]
à l'orée du 19e siècle l'âge de la
machine envahi le monde
[Musique]
le transport la construction et les
progrès industriels connaissent une
nouvelle révolution
[Musique]
le tatouage subit lui aussi sa propre
mutation sur la voie de la mécanisation
des procédés
[Musique]
c'est probablement aux états unis que
fut vécu la plus grande histoire d'amour
vis-à-vis de la révolution industrielle
[Musique]
dans une explosion d'ingéniosité la
nation produisit des machines
extraordinaires dans des formes les plus
diverses
depuis des milliers d'années les
tatouages étaient appliquées avec des
outils manuels qui perçait la peau et
injectait des pigments colorés pour
créer des motifs
c'était une technique qui pouvait
prendre des semaines des mois des années
la révolution industrielle allait
modifier tout cela
[Musique]
new york 1891
dans l'arrière fond d'une boutique de
chatham skweres samuel ou aurélie
tentait de trouver un moyen d'apporter
une touche de technique aux tatouages
après des mois des chèques et de
tentatives infructueuses
aurélie était parvenu à créer la machine
à tatouer
jadis dans les cirques les carnavals les
fois les musées de 4 sous les personnes
tatouées représentait parfaitement les
aspect primitif de cet art
les corps tatoué ces corps nu dans une
certaine mesure présentait un aspect
extraordinaire spectaculaire ou très
différent de la représentation usuels du
corps standards de la classe moyenne
[Musique]
il y avait dans les cirques une
importante demande pour les tatoués
ils étaient vus comme des phénomènes de
la nature comme plus proche des
indigènes primitif que de l'américain
moyen
[Musique]
à la fin des années 20 plus de 300
personnes dont le corps était
entièrement tatoué était employé dans
les cirques américain
ces phénomènes étaient payés jusqu'à 200
dollars la semaine une somme
considérable pour l'époque
[Musique]
un des spectacles de loin le plus
populaire fut celui d'une femme dont le
corps est tatoué de la tête aux pieds
les propriétaires du cirque avait
parfaitement compris l'aspect à la fois
érotique et répulsif d'un tel spectacle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans les années 50 qui suivirent le
tatouage aux états unis reste à l'
apanage des marginaux
[Musique]
marin soldats des guerres autour du
monde avait les leurs
les anti guerre les hippies et autres
adeptes de la culture rock des années 60
participèrent du même mouvement
[Musique]
la quête d'individualisme se transforma
en protestation sociale
[Musique]
aujourd'hui encore l'enthousiasmé lié
aux tatouages à travers le monde se
poursuit notamment au travers de
festivals comme celui de philadelphie
consacrée à la célébration de cet art
on ne parle plus ici d'exhibition de
phénomène car tous les non conformiste
peuvent ici dépassé les limites de leur
art sans encourir la moindre
répercussions
le tatouage permet un contact
instantanée entre gens qui le porte même
s'ils ne se sont jamais rencontrés
[Musique]
en
tant que tu as thouars si quelqu'un me
demande de faire un travail sur son
corps j'essaye de le connaître un peu
mieux et de comprendre les raisons qui
le poussent à faire ce tatouage à
identifier les significations qui s'en
dégage pour lui
[Musique]
entretien avec mes clients une relation
durable vous savez je vais l'enterrement
de tout ce que j'ai et à tous et
je pense qu'il y a une signification
très profonde attaché à la permanence du
tatouage parce que quand vous avez un
tatouage et que vous le regardez vous
vous dites oh mon dieu il ya eu mon
corps d'avant et maintenant il est
différent et je me souviendrai toujours
de ce moment là
et il n'y a rien d'autre que nous
puissions faire nous mêmes qui prennent
cette forme émotionnel
[Musique]
l'héritage du tatouage c'est sa
longévité
cependant la signification culturelle
qui est attaché est tout aussi diverses
que les motifs qui vous sont proposés
une constante se dégage pourtant
le tatouage reste l'expression d'un
individualisme et la tentation d'être à
part
[Musique]